Matt and I are getting ready to go to the Vatican
you have to be fully covered
by the way um
knees and shoulders so I just told my husband that he had to wear pants
not shorts because of his slutty kneecaps
um and I will be wearing this shawl over it
but I wanted to show you all my accessories
so I made this little pearl necklace with blue
it's gonna match so well
and I'm gonna layer with another pearl necklace that I made recently
and then I also have these little
like lemon baroque pearl earrings that I'm gonna wear
and a little bit of a bracelet stack
so the dress is adorable it's J Crew
and then I'm gonna put this over it to cover my
I'm gonna play around with that a little bit
that's the outfit
woo hoo